écoutez je vous propose de commencer
cette audition monsieur le Président
Mesdames Messieurs mes chers collègues
dans le cadre de l'étude que nous menons
sur la continuité territoriale et donc
Catherine Concorde et Guillaume
chevrolier sont rapporteurs
ce matin l'acteur clé du dispositif
public dans ce domaine qui intervient à
travers ses aides financières l'agence
de l'outre-mer pour la mobilité la Dom
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir en
présentiel sans président mail d'Isa son
directeur général Saïda Hamada et sa
secrétaire général Florence vetez
mesdames messieurs nous vous remercions
vivement pour votre disponibilité
monsieur le Président vous allez avoir
la parole pour présenter vos
observations sur la situation actuelle
et les perspectives à venir la base sur
la base d'une trame qui vous a été
communiquée par la délégation selon une
procédure que vous connaissez bien
puisque nous avons eu l'occasion de vous
entendre dans le cadre de vos
précédentes fonctions de délégué
interministériel pour l'égalité des
chances des Français d'outre-mer et de
la visibilité des Outre-mer fonctionne
de 2020 2022 vos observations pourront
être complétées bien évidemment par
Monsieur Saïda madame que nous avons
également plaisir de saluer dans ces
nouvelles fonctions Florence zetez qui a
assuré jusqu'il y a peu de temps la
direction par intérim et qui connaît
particulièrement bien cette
établissement comme vous le savez nous
interrogeons notamment sur la réforme de
la Dom que vous avez la charge conduire
et à laquelle nous souhaitons apporter
notre contribution je laisserai les
rapporteurs intervenir bien sûr pour
vous demander des précisions ainsi que
nos autres collègues qui j'en suis
certain auront beaucoup de questions à
vous poser monsieur le Président vous
avez la parole pour votre présentation
générale avant d'entrer dans le détail
des questions
merci monsieur le Président
je voudrais juste préciser ma technique
sur les les différentes structures donc
la délégation est toujours et donc je
suis encore cumulable pour le moment en
tant que délégué pendant de la DOM et
donc effectivement une un projet de
rapprochement entre les structures qui
étaient annoncées par le ministre en
septembre dernier nous y travaillons du
coup nous en parlerons dans le déroulé
et donc il y a bien effectivement encore
les deux structures qui travaillent pour
l'instant sur des périmètres distincts
qui ont vocation pour le coup à se
rejoindre et faire une structure globale
sur une vision périphérique sur tous les
sujets
très bien alors sur le sur le déroulé je
pense être transparent qu'il y a eu un
petit loupé entre nous parce qu'on n'a
pas eu de tram
en amont en tout cas elle ne peut pas
revenue du coup nous avons comment
préparer les éléments qui je pense vont
se rejoindre sur sur les questions du
jour
donc c'est ça vous va on va
alors peut-être chez nous qui est loupé
hein je veux pas dire pas de souci
très bien
je pense que de toute façon ils
rejoindront vraisemblablement les propos
que vous allez tenir donc absolument
alors ce que nous avions prévu c'était
de commencer par présenter la Dom en
l'état actuel et donc j'ai laisserai
madame des thèse ou le directeur le
faire puis après je comptais présenter
la délégation que vous connaissez
évidemment après le projet final et puis
après rentrer dans les différents points
techniques un parent et puisque je vous
propose également par la suite c'est de
pouvoir nous apporter un support écrit
ici aux questions qui ne répètent pas pu
traiter aujourd'hui donc voilà on va le
faire de manière très simple et très
opérationnelle pour pouvoir apporter les
réponses qu'elles soient en présentiel
ou par la suite à l'issue de cette
audition il y a aucune difficulté bien
sûr très bien
sur la Dom je vous laisse présenter son
global oui merci
[Musique]
donc comme vous l'avez précisé je suis
nouvellement arrivé au fonctionnement de
directeur général de la Dom ça fait
exactement un mois aujourd'hui
que le décret paru donc sur la partie
j'allais dire antériorité je laisserai
madame je vais test qui a assuré avec
brio l'intérim pendant les 10 derniers
mois vous donnez vous alimentez
notamment en matière de chiffres et de
résultats d'activités
pour ce qui me concerne je vais
peut-être vous présenter je pense que ça
mérite d'être fait notamment pour celles
et ceux qui je pense que vous êtes
complètement fait mais évidemment je le
sais beaucoup de personnes suivent ces
auditions présentés rapidement la Dom
dans ces dans ces missions principales
et son organisation
donc la dame ou Lady monsieur le
sénateur travaille à la mobilité à la
mobilité des
ultramarins c'est l'outil principal de
la mobilité des ultramarins à
disposition du gouvernement donc sous
tutelle du ministère de l'Outre-mer et
du ministère du Budget
18 représentations en tel ou direction
territoriale donc implantation sur les
territoires
si ça d'outre-mer et le reste en
hexagone et des gains avec avec les
comme nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui de
représentation physique mais avec
lesquelles nous travaillons de manière
active très régulièrement
quotidiennement
pour ce qui est des outils principaux
aujourd'hui à disposition des
bénéficiaires de la Dom nous avons pour
les étudiants qu'on appelle le PME
passeport mobilité pour les études qui
permet aux étudiants
boursiers d'avoir un financement à 100%
de leur biais pour venir étudier dans
l'Hexagone
et à autant de 50% pour les autres
pour ce qui est de la formation
professionnelle donc passeport mobilité
formation professionnelle là aussi la
possibilité pour celles et ceux qui
souhaitent un outre-mer venir se former
soit dans leur région je précise donc
la zone régionale y compris d'ailleurs
dans les pays de la zone
soit en hexagone pour des formations qui
sont soit inexistantes sur place soit
saturées c'est aussi important à
préciser on offre la possibilité donc à
ces personnes là de venir se former
acquérir des compétences et ensuite
revenir si elle le souhaite c'est le cas
de d'une personne sur deux dans leur
territoire d'origine pour continuer à
continuer à y travailler et puis vous
avez la CT vous connaissez bien là de la
continuité territoriale qui sous
conditions de ressources permet tous les
trois ans évoluent à un ultra marin de
venir pour raison familiale diverses
foiré on investit pas et on n'a pas
savoir pour la raison pour laquelle elle
vient mais
va pouvoir financer co-financer le
billet sous forme de de bon
madame Vettel je vous dira du coup en
nombre ce que cela représente et en
pourcentage du billet je pense que c'est
un sujet dans la période actuelle on est
autour de 40 % de prise en charge de
billets ce qui est quand même pas
négligeable
sous conditions de ressources pour tous
les dispositifs dont je vous ai parlé
évidemment puisque il s'agit de
permettre à ceux qui ont le moins de
moyens de pouvoir accès à avoir accès à
ces assez dispositifs et un
épanouissement professionnel ou des
liens familiaux je terminerai pas dire
que et c'est ce qui m'anime c'est la
raison pour laquelle du coup j'ai
accepté cette mission il s'agit d'une
vraie mission de service public
c'est-à-dire qu'on est ni une agence de
voyage ni une succursale de Pôle Emploi
on travaille au lien entre les hommes et
les femmes entre les Français ou qu'ils
soient sur le territoire première
élément deuxième élément c'est la
possibilité d'ouvrir le champ des
possibles pour tous les Français ou
qu'ils soient
et que la question de la mobilité ne
soit pas un frein autant que faire ce
peu avec le moyen qui sont les nôtres
qu'un jeune ou un moins jeune qui habite
à Paris intra-muros à Fort de France ou
à Cayenne et les mêmes chances de
réussite et qu'il soit uniquement limité
par
ses compétences intellectuelles
techniques manuel c'est à mon sens le
rôle de la République et c'est la
mission j'allais dire principale
principale de la dame
sur la partie un peu plus un peu plus
chiffré
pour le en 2022 les chiffres viennent
d'être stabilisés en termes
d'accompagnement
d'achat de billets à taux plein donc
comme le directeur général ou à taux à
moitié moitié tarif on est sur le
l'accompagnement des étudiants à 9276
étudiants accompagnés sur les
territoires Drôme pour un montant de
14000 enfin 15 millions
pour ce qu'on appelle nous
l'accompagnement à la continuité
territoriale c'est-à-dire l'émission de
bon aller-retour pour les personnes qui
veulent venir en hexagone soit pour le
loisir voir leur famille un lien
économique soit dans le cadre du du
funéraire soit dans les assétés
spécifiques que sont l'accompagnement
des doctorants des sportifs de des
sportifs à venir et des artistes on a
émis 48
000 bons pour un montant payé de 14
millions cette année
avec un report de 2 millions sur un
année d'après donc en tout cette année
notre activité a généré 16 millions de
frais pour la Dom pour autour de la CT
le pmfp qui
pour nous là en termes de commission
mais il y a les chiffres plus fins qui
vous parviendront par mail sur
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
puisque la Dom a en charge donc les
demandeurs d'emploi qui veulent exercer
une mobilité vers l'Hexagone ou dans le
bassin de vie et puis
et puis les loisirs on va dire pour
faire court on est dans les DROM
dans les dromes à 1984 personnes
accompagnées et dans les com à 103
personnes accompagnées
principalement Polynésie une
Nouvelle-Calédonie à la marge
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
pour un montant de 13 millions 3 puisque
là on prend en charge les rémunérations
si besoin l'aide à l'installation et le
billet à plein taux et le transport lié
à cette action et de 3 millions de
donc vous l'aurez deviné l'impact pour
2022 a été pour la DOME le budget de la
domination du prix des billets d'avion
qui a représenté un surcoût de 46
dans ce cadre là
avec le président Maël d'Isa et le
ministre y a été travaillé avec la DG om
aussi
une éventuelle augmentation des bons
acétés pour les personnes qui veulent
voyager et dont le coup du billet était
prohibitif donc le nouvel arrêté devrait
paraître bientôt pour augmenter le
niveau du bon au niveau du bon
actuellement il est fixé par territoire
il est entre 270 et 4 pour la zone
Caraïbes et Mayotte 440
en passant par la réunion à 360 euros
par billet d'avion
pas par aller-retour pardon ça ce sont
les chiffres de l'activité
alors sur il y avait la question sur le
dans votre tram sur le partenariat avec
Pôle Emploi effectivement
la Dom a toujours faim depuis très
longtemps un partenariat avec Pôle
emploi en 202 septembre 2021 a été signé
un partenariat qui prend effet en
premier janvier 2020 Capri effet au 1er
janvier 2022 et qui pour une année de
transition
[Musique]
d'accompagnement différent des du
personnel de la Dom c'est à dire que la
Dom avant prescrivait quand un
ultramarin avait un projet de mobilité
vers l'Hexagone pour une formation qui
était demandeur d'emploi la Dom
prescrivait la formation trouver la
formation à travers un marché et trouver
le logement toujours à travers ce marché
et accompagner la personne sur le
territoire hexagonal pendant sa
formation et jusqu'à six mois après en
2022 avec la loi liberté travail la Dom
n'est plus prescriptif donc on travaille
avec Pôle Emploi différemment et on
partage autour du bénéficiaire qui peut
soit devenir à la Dom soit devenir à
Pôle emploi et après il y a un échange
entre Pôle emploi et la Dom pour
accompagner au mieux le bénéficiaire
soit avec les aides de Pôle emploi soit
avec les aides de la Dom ce partenariat
a
change quand même beaucoup de
la façon de faire
avec
avec beaucoup de représentations
de Pôle emploi sur les territoires donc
il a fallu un temps d'appropriation un
peu important
ce qui n'a pas conduit à une activité
telle qu'on espérait en 2022 et qui
tente à s'améliorer en 2023 en tout cas
en fin d'année on a vu une hausse on
voit que le travail avance
voilà et l'avantage de ce partenariat
l'avantage premier c'est que les
ultramarins ont accès à tout le
catalogue formation Pôle emploi et donc
priori plus de possibilités sachant que
la Dom n'accompagne et je pense Pôle
Emploi aussi que quand la filière ou la
formation n'existe pas sur le territoire
ou quelle est saturée sinon ce qui est
privilégié avant tout c'est de faire la
formation sur le territoire d'origine
donc le prix du billet on en a parlé je
regarde en même temps la trame sur
il y avait une question sur le transport
de corps
effectivement il y a très peu de
de
demande et quand il a demandé elles sont
pas toutes éligibles elles sont sous
plafond de ressources ces demandes donc
tout ce qui est accompagnement à la
continuité territoriale en tant que tel
et sous plafond de ressources à 11191
euros par fiscale et parfois foyer tout
ce qui est pmfp et sous plafond
aussi mais pour 26000
26300 euros par fiscale donc le
transport de corps est soumis à plafond
fiscal et puis nous intervenons sur le
remboursement
nous n'avançons pas les frais et c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai frein puisque si
l'avant c'est fait soit par Nelson
sociale soit par un CCAS local on ne
peut plus intervenir donc ça ne facilite
pas l'accès à ce dispositif la Région
Réunion a voulu avec nous faire une
convention pour que une prise en charge
immédiate et
de leur part avec un système de
remboursement de notre part ou un
cofinancement par les textes ce n'est
pas permis
sur la question 10 sur l'accompagnement
des étudiants mais peut-être monsieur
disard va en parler
oui alors peut-être je refais dans le
désordre et vous m'excuserez mais pour
reprendre un peu le consommer que tout
le monde et bien le film donc
effectivement donc il y a eu la Dom par
les évolutions législatives dont tu as
parlé madame zetez sur le sujet Pôle
emploi et le rapprochement fait que la
DOM et les missions de ses
collaborateurs vont évoluer ce que
toutes ces parties prescription qui
était avant un élément fort de leur
activité
pour parler simplement entre guillemets
sous traiter désormais à Pôle emploi et
donc cela va libérer du temps pouvoir
faire autre chose et donc c'est dans cet
esprit que ce rapprochement entre
délégation un message et la Dom a lieu
pour se dire comment utiliser au mieux
ce ton libérer pour donner à la Dom des
nouvelles missions en commençant par
reprendre certaines missions qui avaient
la délégation par exemple nous allons
maintenant parler du logement les fois
d'avant jusqu'à présent la Dom
accompagné sur la billetterie les
étudiants et ces mêmes étudiants étaient
accompagnés sur le logement par la
délégation peut-être que désormais ces
étudiants pourraient être global
accompagnés sur les deux thèmes par la
même personne et donc l'idée était de
faire se rapprochement pour pouvoir
aussi faciliter l'accompagnement et
rendre nos meilleurs services aux
étudiants et ensuite il y a le sujet des
nouvelles missions qui correspond au
point dont sur la question 7 sur quels
seront du coup demain les nouvelles
missions les lames 2024 donc on pourra
rentrer dans le détail et donc c'est
dans cet esprit qu'il y a désormais ce
sujet de rapprochement et donc l'idée
d'aboutir à l'issue de cette année à ce
qu'on appelle entre nous le nouveau
LADOM ou la donne 2024 dans un certain
nombre de réflexions et de concertation
a eu lieu et qui va aboutir du coup à
solidifier l'existant et aussi traiter
de nouveaux sujets de nouvelles missions
donc dans cet esprit là que nous sommes
pour le coup tous les trois aujourd'hui
où il y a ces changements à la fois de
personnes
ma nomination par la ministre comme
personne qualifiée puis mon élection
de ca a provocation à faciliter cette
transition le fait que je sois dans les
deux structures permet de faciliter et à
la fois la continuité qu'on aime des
thèse et l'arrivée de Monsieur Amada
nous permet de mettre tout ça en place
cette année et nous avons comme objectif
de créer en 2024 un la Dom avec des
missions élargies qui pour accompagner
les étudiants notamment et le public
cible sur un périmètre plus large et
donc c'est ce qui amène du coup à
répondre aux questions qui sont opposées
alors je sais pas si on continue à
dérouler les questions est-ce que vous
voulez déjà
on rentre des caisses des commentaires
sur nos premières premiers éléments ou
autre chose je vous propose qu'on
continue à dérouler autant que possible
et puis après je laisserai la parole aux
rapporteur puis à nos collègues qui sont
présents ou à distance d'accord
donc du coup on va reprendre l'ordre
j'imagine ou peut-être des éléments
jusqu'à des éléments de réponse qui vous
ont déjà été apportées donc je pense que
si vous voulez des précisions on pourra
vous les donner notamment sur le premier
pack de questions sur les sur la sur ce
que Monsieur disait bien d'évoquer
notamment l'évolution de l'évolution de
la Dom qui me paraît très importante
parce que c'est qu'on arrive à se
projeter on a en effet un projet la dame
de Big 24
[Musique]
élèves parce que je pense que ça aura
aussi des incidences budgétaires donc
assemblés pour arriver à avoir un outil
complètement opérationnel dès le 1er
janvier de l'année prochaine en tout cas
notre notre ambition parce que la
question est posée on peut déjà
d'abord vous dire qu'avant 2024 il y a
et que c'est en lien d'ailleurs avec
l'occasion sur un rapport Cours des
comptes et
Associés c'est à dire que on a une
structure aujourd'hui qui financièrement
est saine
il faut que l'on arrive à consolider nos
acquis consolider nos process pour être
en capacité de se projeter justement sur
de nouvelles missions
l'accord avec Pôle Emploi le partenaire
Pôle emploi et à mon sens bénéfique qui
permet de faire bénéficier ou d'offrir
aux
ultramarins panel de formation que l'on
n'avait pas auparavant
et ce qui nous permet nous c'est un peu
comme Monsieur disait de nos concentrer
ce qu'il y a mon sens et notre corps de
métier ce qui est ce qui doit être
l'accompagnement c'est à dire on doit
être aller à mon sens les personnes qui
sont les référentes mobilités pour les
outre-mer et les ultramarins avec une
différence entre les deux mais j'irai je
vous expliquerai à quoi je pense lorsque
je dis ça et donc cette année 2023 doit
être l'année de la consolidation et du
retour à une activité
à dire normal après les périodes de
confinement et qui ont forcément eu un
impact sur les mobilités je pense que
vous êtes très bien placé pour le pour
le savoir
et donc sur la projection en 2024 à mon
sens mais on est vraiment au sens des au
stade des réflexions c'est pour ça que
et c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs
qu'on puisse qu'on puisse en discuter
je pense que la Dom qui est l'agence
pour la mobilité
doit être l'Agence pour la mobilité dans
les deux sens
[Musique]
hexagone et qui souhaitent aller
s'installer sur ces territoires qui
souhaitent apporter leur expérience leur
expertise qu'un projet de vie même ça va
être aussi des personnes qui sont
pourquoi pas à la retraite mais pour
voir les accompagner ça veut dire que le
travail que l'on fait aujourd'hui qui
est la compagnie des notamment des
personnes qui sont en mobilité
professionnelle en leur trouvant un
logement en les accueillant à l'aéroport
accepter etc on doit être capable en
capacité de le faire aussi dans les
territoires d'outre-mer et c'est quelque
part aussi notre
ADN mais en tout cas notre notre
plus-value que d'abord autant de
représentations sur le territoire
exagonal il n'y a pas beaucoup de
d'agences vous le savez qui ont autant
de représentation et outre-mer et
hexagone donc je pense que ça il faut
qu'on l'utilise collectivement pour être
au service des territoires ça me
semestre un élément un élément
extrêmement important
pour revenir un peu sur Madame GPS
pourraient aussi compléter parce que
elle a mené des consultations mais
il y a quelques items qui reviennent sur
les sur les besoins de ces territoires
aujourd'hui on s'adresse pas aux actifs
on travaille pas avec les actifs qui ont
besoin de formation professionnelle je
pense qu'il faut qu'on soit en capacité
de le faire demain
si tout cela bien sûr est validé pour
les étudiants
on finance on confinance le billet
d'avion
moi je souhaiterais que l'on puisse au
moins sur la première année parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous le savez peut-être
mais en bilan c'est un billet d'avion
par dire par étudiant aller-retour
c'est-à-dire que il part et il a
possibilité de revenir et souvent les
études durant si on prend la licence ou
le BTS en deux ans ou trois ans
c'est-à-dire qu'il revient au bout des
trois ans je pense que la première année
comme la phase d'acclimatation quand
même est assez compliquée il serait
intéressant de pouvoir offrir un
aller-retour par exemple au moment des
fêtes de Noël la première liste quand
même c'est quand même une année cruciale
on a des jeunes 18 19 ans 20 ans donc je
pense que voilà cette année un peu
charnière il me semble être importante
pour pouvoir offrir cette nouvelle
possibilité d'un aller-retour
supplémentaires et puis on
accompagnement qu'on ne fait pas
aujourd'hui et que les CROUS ont du mal
à faire
t'accompagnement des ultramarins
lorsqu'ils arrivent sur le territoire
et le fait qu'on est nos équipes autant
d'implantations et une expérience de
l'accompagnement sur la formation
professionnelle me semble
nous pousser en tout cas moi je le
souhaite a aussi accompagner les
étudiants dans leur implantation sur le
territoire hexagonal les démarches
caffent les démarches de recharge de
logement de liens avec le CROUS de
facilitateur en fait sur sur le sur le
territoire hexagonal
et je terminerai sur sur à mon sens
le rôle puisque on a plus j'allais dire
ce volet formation qui est exercée
aujourd'hui par Pôle emploi mais il
reste quand même le travail qu'on fait
avec les régions ou là aussi il y a des
formations que sur lesquelles on peut
émerger et qui sort du coup du cadre
Pôle emploi et demain si on est sur les
actifs on sera plus dans On n'est pas
non plus dans le cadre Pôle Emploi donc
pour l'emploi est un partenaire
important mais pas le seul aujourd'hui
on travaille déjà beaucoup avec les
régions avec lesquels on signe
régulièrement des accords
pour accompagner des des bénéficiaires
ce que je souhaiterais à terme mais ça
du coup je vous livre mais c'est une
réflexion personnelle je le répète c'est
que la DOM
que ce soit en outre-mer ou que ce soit
en hexagone soit le premier guichet de
celles et ceux qui pensent à outre-mer
et mobilité
c'est-à-dire que une personne à hexagone
qui soit de se projeter dans les autres
mères se disent je m'adresse à la DOM et
la Dom puisque nous avons les CIP ce
qu'on appelle conseiller d'insertion
professionnelle que c'est conseillé
jouent pleinement l'oral de conseiller
et accompagne ces
personnes là dans leur projet de vie
vers les territoires d'outre-mer qu'il
soit ou pas accompagné par des objectifs
de la demande en interne mais qu'on soit
en capacité de les orienter vers les
bonnes les bonnes personnes les bons
organismes pour que la dire le
déplacement de ce la construction de ce
projet de vie se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions et de la même manière dans
dans notre mer qu'on soit aussi les
référents mobilités
pense à une formation professionnelle
pense à un projet de vie ailleurs que
sur son territoire que ce soit dans la
région ou dans l'Hexagone qui des se
réflexe la DOM et que la Dom se charge
ensuite en gros tout ce qui sera
lien avec les organismes hyper et variés
tout sera ce sera la tout ça sera de la
tuyauterie interne et qui est un
interlocuteur à peu près unique et un
parcours qui permettent de ne pas perdre
ces jeunes ou ses moins jeunes qui ont
ce projet de vie de mobilité liées à une
mobilité sur la zone ou sur ou sur
l'hexagone donc voilà comme premier
élément peut-être pour répondre à
vos questions sur ce que peut-être
l'avenir de la Dom demain
il y avait aussi une question qui s'est
recoupe les propos sur notre
les accords qu'on a avec des régions
enfin les conventions qu'on a avec les
régions et départements actuellement
nous avons autour de la formation et de
l'emploi des conventions financières
c'est à dire que les régions et
départements nous
avons un travail commun eux les régions
ont la capacité de prescrire donc il
prescrivent les formations et nous on
les met en oeuvre en cherchant
l'organisme de formation conjointement
avec les régions donc c'est les régions
qui décident de qui part qui partent
nous on vérifie les éligibilité on
accompagne sur le territoire hexagonal
ensuite donc on a une convention avec la
Martinique la Guadeloupe Mayotte et
Saint-Martin
et pour en France hexagonale on a aussi
des conventions avec les régions même si
c'est inscrit dans la loi et que
n'importe quel français donc il soit
peut avoir accès à la formation proposée
par exemple pour la région à Rhône-Alpes
on a des accords quand même privilégiés
pour pas oublier de prendre en compte
les besoins des
ultramarins on a des conventions aussi
avec des bailleurs sociaux pour trouver
des logements plus facilement et un
frein alors des conventions sans enjeu
financier mais pour pour sceller des
partenariats et mieux travailler
ensemble je pense notamment à aux EPCI
en Guadeloupe parfois on a des accords
pour faire de la promotion commune
autour de la formation
en mobilité sachant que
quand on fait nos statistiques à 6 mois
il y a 75% des personnes qu'on a
accompagnées qui sont insérées dans
l'emploi et quand on fait nos
statistiques aussi et à 50% des
personnes qui retournent sur leur
territoire d'origine alors immédiatement
mais peuvent retourner après mais on a
plus de suivi donc et puis elles peuvent
retourner juste après et puis repartir
comme ça on n'a pas le suivi donc on
peut pas c'est pas très fin mais en tout
cas on a du retour à 50% puisqu'on prend
en charge le billet retour
sur sur ce dispositif
toujours en termes de la continuité
territoriale vous avez une question sur
le
rendu de la Cour administrative d'appel
de Bordeaux qui dit en gros que les
régions ne peuvent pas prendre en charge
ça peut pas faire partie si je fais
grossir moi pas prendre en charge les
frais de continuité territoriale entre
l'hexagone et
les territoires ultramarins alors c'est
c'est une histoire qui vient de la
Réunion me semble-t-il la région avait
pris en charge cette mission
nous en gros en tant que établissement
public administratif on est garant d'une
équité sur tous les territoires je peux
vous dire que ça par rapport à cette à
ce à ce travail là enfin mais la Cour
d'appel a administrative a dit que
c'était pas normal que enfin que ce soit
les régions
moi j'ai pas d'opinion à ce sujet plus
que je peux vous dire que nous on a
établissement public donc on met les
mêmes moyens surtout les territoires
mais je ne peux pas cerner plus cette
cette décision de la Cour administrative
qui antérieure à mon arrivée dont j'ai
pas suivi les premiers pas mais on peut
essayer de vous apporter une réponse si
quelqu'un veut à une spécification de
cette question
plus en amont que ce que écrit dans le
texte on peut essayer de répondre
pour en finir je pour compléter les
propos de Monsieur à Hamada sur la
consultation Adam 2024 la première des
demandes des territoires ultramarins
c'est d'améliorer nos propres
dispositifs par comme la dit Monsieur à
Madame l'accompagnement des étudiants la
prise en compte du handicap des choses
qui sont utiles à la population la
deuxième demande est plus située au
niveau de la prise en charge des
salariés avec la réforme des OPCO pour
les frais de
déplacement et de d'hébergement et le
troisième point le plus cité c'est
l'accompagnement au retour ou à
l'installation
sur les territoires en fait dans
l'esprit
enfin c'est pour accompagner le
développement des territoires et sorti
de sortir
un peu de l'aide à la personne mais de
plus s'inscrire dans le développement du
territoire local pour permettre son
développement économique et social
si vous avez je pense couvert le tour
d'horizon à ce stade je vous propose
peut-être qu'on passe la parole au
rapporteur qui pourront peut-être
demander des précisions et puis ensuite
à nos collègues qui sont présents et à
distance je laisse la parole je ne sais
pas Catherine peut-être
chaque Catherine oui bonjour président
oui pourquoi pas bonjour à toutes et à
tous
bonjour monsieur le Président de la Dom
shermael Monsieur le Directeur et
Madame la directrice a été rime à
l'époque
il y a plusieurs choses qui
m'interpellent enfin j'ai déjà été
plusieurs conditionné par la dôme au
moins trois fois je pense depuis
l'époque du ministère de Madame Girardet
pour ce nouvel album que
tout le monde appelle de ses vœux ce qui
ce qui m'a toujours choqué
particulièrement c'est ce plafond de
ressources
qu'il faut donc il faut faire preuve
pour bénéficier de la Dom 11000 euros
vous venez de rappeler le chiffre enfin
11000 et quelques euros c'est très très
bas comme comme
plafond la deuxième chose c'est
le souhait que tout le monde formule que
cette affaire de la continuité
territoriale soit la plus équitable
possible sur les territoires nous avons
additionné la Corse ici
et on est très loin du compte si on doit
comparer même si la course est plus près
que les billets sont forcément moins
cher et tout on est vraiment très loin
du compte en matière d'équité mais
vraiment très loin du compte je ne parle
même pas des montants
et mon temps c'est plus de 200 millions
d'euros d'accord bon on va comparer ce
qui est comparable mais les conditions
d'accès les critères et tout on est
vraiment très très loin du compte donc
si il y a quelque chose qui doit guider
la donne
quelque chose de transversal qui doit
guider la dôme dans sa réforme si c'est
trop cher d'équité je parle même pas
d'égalité parce que dans le domaine les
territoires sont tellement différents il
y a tellement de critères différents on
pourra pas parler d'égalité mais comment
qui est de l'équité en terme d'accès à
la continuité territoriale la troisième
chose qui est pour moi extrêmement
importante c'est le traitement
différencier par le territoire nous
avons par exemple Guadeloupe et
Martinique qui sont des territoires des
peuplement il ne faut pas donner
l'impression qu'elle adore vient
faire une saignée de plus dans ce
territoire qui perd si je pars de la
Martinique environ un peu plus de 10 ans
a perdu 50000 âmes 50000 âmes et passer
de 400 000 à moins de 350 000 habitants
aujourd'hui avec une part de jeunes de
plus en plus faible par rapport à une
part de de personnes de plus de 65 ans
donc il faut vraiment travailler à
territorialisé en fonction des besoins
et que même pour les formations on ne
soit pas dans des formations
dans lesquelles on envoie les gens pour
le principe on veut faire une formation
n'importe laquelle et on peut partir il
faut vraiment cibler les métiers en
tension je crois que Madame la
diététicienne jouait ton a parlé les
métiers en tension et travailler à la
construction de projets de développement
économique et humains par le territoire
ça c'est vraiment très important la
dernière chose que je voulais vous
demander qu'est-ce que l'album a prévu
pour être plus accessible plus visible
il y a des difficultés énormes à pouvoir
souvent rentrer en contact avec la Dom
l'essentiel des procédures se passe par
Internet il y a dans certaines
territoires des gens qui sont en
fracture avec Internet qui savent pas
l'utiliser je pense peut-être pas aux
étudiants qui qui sont venus de cette
génération là les jeunes mais je parle
aux personnes un peu plus âgées
qui ont par exemple le projet de vie en
termes de formation et qui pour qui
l'accès à Internet est un vrai problème
enfin comment là aussi on travaille la
meilleure accès on voit bien que les
montants les montants sont faibles pour
tout ce qui concerne la continuité
funéraire et le et l'accès des sportif
on sait qu'il y a des sportifs et
artistes il y a des fonds au ministère
de l'Outre-mer ce fameux faibec aussi
qui qui a été augmenté et qui pourtant
à des montres des chiffres qui sont pas
très très qui sont pas terribles en
matière de consommation il y a la
possibilité de la Dom à quel moment on
crée une espèce de guichet unique entre
toutes ces formules qui permettraient à
une troupe de théâtre un orchestre ou à
des sportifs de partir plus facilement
pour leur entraînement c'est le parcours
du combattant aujourd'hui quand artistes
ou des sportifs doivent se déplacer si
bien que souvent il renonce à un contrat
il renonce ou alors des dirigeants
sportifs qui sont pris dans des
promotions qu'ils doivent assumer parce
qu'on passe d'une division à une autre
d'une poule à une autre et bien ont
toutes les peines du monde ils se
retrouvent souvent aller mendier de la
des lettres trésorerie auprès des
agences de voyages et je peux vous dire
que je reçois des dirigeants sportifs
qui sont parfois désespérés et au bord
de ne pas pouvoir partir
fierté ou tel match ou tel ou tel stage
sur sur le territoire français alors
vraiment comment travaille à tout cela
et puis et puis pour terminer vraiment
le volet retour de la dôme qui était
prévu à l'origine on en a là où je m'en
discuté à l'époque avec Flo business
star et Philippe Jock quand ils étaient
à gouvernance de la Dom à quel moment
travaille au retour des populations dans
le dans leur pays à quel moment un
billet retour peut être donné sans avoir
eu un billet aller il y a aujourd'hui
des jeunes qui veulent rentrer en
Martinique par exemple et au vu de notre
situation démographique ce sont des
aubaines pour nous chaque retour est une
pépite mais il faut pouvoir trouver un
kit de de
suivi d'aide dans le cadre de la
mobilité retour sur des métiers
attention sur des stages à effectuer au
pays sur des jurys
auxquels il faut répondre et tout cette
semaine encore j'ai rencontré un jeune
qui rentre qui est passé trois jury il a
dû prendre ce billet d'avion sur ses
propres fronts pour tenter de d'être
accepté dans un emploi en Martinique et
en tout cas être dans son souhait de
rentrer au pays
voilà pour mes questions pour l'instant
je propose de pouvoir répondre et puis
après je serai la parole peut-être
Guillaume chevrolier pour pour enchaîner
bien merci madame la sénatrice alors
peut-être je vais juste faire un point
pardon
vous vouliez pas non oui peut-être je
vais juste faire un point de un peu de
vision et puis je vous laisserai
Florence et Saïd de faire la suite moi
je voulais dire que déjà je pense que
totalement d'accord tout ce qui a été
dit nous avons eu l'occasion d'échanger
précédemment et donc évidemment sur la
vision il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de
difficulté et aussi
s'il a été fait ce choix de personnes
maintenant ou à la direction c'est aussi
pour impulser ce que vous avez dit et
j'ai envie de dire que la seule limite
qui se posait à nous c'est financier
évidemment les dispositifs n'existant et
il était fait le choix à l'origine de
les restreindre un public très précaires
évidemment ils existent ils ont vocation
exister pour tout le monde et tout le
monde en a besoin même les personnes les
plus les moins précaires des territoires
dans les conditions actuels un billet
d'avion reste un billet d'avion reste un
investissement important
et donc sur le sujet juste vous les
précisez pas pour vous parce que vous
savez mais puisqu'on nous sommes écoutés
enregistrés que la Dom n'intervient
vraiment depuis son origine
exclusivement que sur des formations
inexistantes ou saturées la DOME
n'intervient pas quand il y a sur place
la même filière et donc il y a vraiment
une volonté historique de la DOM et
évidemment nous-mêmes depuis mais de
toujours de pas du tout rentrer en
concurrence ou pas du tout d'offrir
d'alternative en métropole s'il existe
sur place une possibilité et donc ça
c'est un point cardinal de la Dom qui va
pour qu'il va être poursuivi et pour
lequel vraiment nous faisons nos
meilleurs efforts
systématiquement nous sommes sollicités
même en direct par des personnes qui
aimeraient être accompagnées sur un
billet d'avion et quand on se rend
compte par nous-mêmes qu'il y a sur
place l'option évidemment qu'il n'y a
pas d'accompagnement possible
[Musique]
très précisément
sur le sujet des dispositifs je
laisserai évidemment madame DTS et
Monsieur Hamada répondre et je voudrais
juste préciser quelque chose
qu'effectivement est une difficulté ce
sont les plateformes de ressources
vous avez raison madame la sénatrice le
chiffre de 12000 euros par part de
familiale est très faible alors c'est
par parent donc c'est pas pour le foie
il sait pas par le foyer c'est vraiment
par part donc si il y a un couple chacun
une part puis les enfants c'est que
c'est très faible et donc nous sommes
pour le coup en train de faire une étude
pour vraiment cibler nombre de personnes
qui seraient éligibles sur le territoire
et par rapport à son médecin éligibles
combien d'entre eux font appel à la DOM
et combien par un milieu qui ont fait
appel à Dom malgré cela ne partent pas
parce que le rester à charge est trop
important ce qu'on voit quand même et
c'est une de nos tristesse quotidienne
c'est que la Dom a dispositif qui qui
existe dans les crédits sont mobilisés
et le magret cela les gens ne partent
pas parce que quand le reste à charge
est de 1000 euros même si vous êtes aidé
à 50% à 80% à 90%
c'est les 10% restants c'est 1000 euros
mais faut les sortir et donc malgré cela
notamment à Mayotte on voit qu'il y a
quand même beaucoup de personnes qui
font la demande de bon et qu'il
n'utilisent pas et c'est là où c'est
vraiment une tristesse de voir que les
crédits sont là et qu'on n'arrive pas à
les utiliser donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
un travail vraiment de refonte sur les
critères de ressources et notre seule
limite sera les les budgets votés en PLF
et donc évidemment qu'on sera demandeur
d'aide pour pouvoir que ces budgets
soient augmentés et pour pouvoir toucher
aux populations le plus large possible
je vous laisse répondre sur les sujets
dont je reprends le fil sur le sur le
plafond de ressources
ce qui ce qui alors c'est vrai que le
plafond le plafond est bas mais pour
objectif les choses
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire avec
notamment la DGFiP on a souhaité avoir
on souhaite avoir ce qu'on a toujours
pas
la connaissance de du potentiel à dire
en tout cas du nombre de personnes qui
potentiellement pourrait s'adresser à la
Dom sur chacun des territoires sur
chacun des territoires je pense que par
exemple sur Mayotte malheureusement ce
que le niveau de richesse est
relativement relativement bas par
rapport aux autres territoires
ultramarais encore pire par rapport à
l'Hexagone il y a plus de personnes
potentiellement éligibles que sur
d'autres territoires
de d'outre-mer et donc déjà savoir de
quoi on parle quel est le public
aujourd'hui éligible ce qui nous
permettra d'avoir de manière très
objective de savoir si rapporter à la
population on a un impact potentiel qui
peut
on peut avoir potentiellement un impact
sur les sur les sur les territoires
c'est-à-dire que si sur un territoire
vous avez 1% de la population qui
éligible aux aides de la Dom il faut
qu'on se pose la question réellement du
plafond de ressources là il est
clairement trop bas je rejoint
d'ailleurs ce que Madame Cancun disait
madame sénatrice sur le fait de
territorialiser un peu nos aides si sur
Mayotte on est sur une personne sur deux
du coup personne ressource on peut dire
qu'il est au niveau vous voyez ce que je
veux dire et et à partir de ça première
les voir à Faction et deuxième niveau
réflexion que m'a déjà évoqué aussi
c'est savoir quel est notre
couverture voilà c'est pas très joli
mais c'est un peu ça veut dire sur le
potentiel que l'on a sur ces territoires
combien de personnes s'adressent à la
Dom alors ça peut être et celle qui ne
s'adresse pas à nous soit nous
connaissent pas de projet etc mais ce
qui nous permet en comparant les
territoires de savoir si par exemple sur
la Martinique on touche une personne sur
deux ou une personne sur deux s'adresse
à nous ou s'est adressé à nous
pour des projets de mobilité qu'ils
aboutissent ou pas et que sur notre
territoire on est sur une personne sur
quatre voire moins on a ça nous donne
nous des indicateurs d'activités pour
savoir où est-ce qu'on doit porter
l'effort et savoir ce qui est adapté ou
qu'il ne l'est pas ce travail jusqu'à
présent n'avait pas été fait ce qui nous
permettra d'être plus proche des
territoires là aussi et de la réalité
des territoires du niveau de vie parce
que je le disais le code des transports
non régime que les transports permet
justement d'avoir des plafonds de
ressources adaptées au niveau de vie des
territoires
donc ce que l'on ce que l'on peut porter
ou ce que l'on va essayer de porter
c'est justement cette approche
territorialisée pour essayer d'avoir des
choses qui soient adaptées ce qui est
territoire sont différents vous le savez
aussi bien que moi même s'il y a des
points communs il y a quand même aussi
de grosses différences qu'il faut qu'on
soit en capacité de prendre en compte
sur l'aspect de la
démographie de certains territoires
alors c'est un vrai sujet et qui nous
qui nous interpelle c'est-à-dire qui
nous inquiète en tout cas qui nous
interpelle qui doit tous nous
interpeller je pense que on doit tous
travailler à l'attractivité une
meilleure attractivité de certains
territoires on parle d'outre-mer ça vaut
aussi pour certaines territoires ruraux
et
je pense qu'il faut il faut il faut
qu'on distingue les choses comme mettre
les je pense les les
responsabilités au bon niveau
notre rôle c'est pour ça que j'ai un peu
insisté là-dessus et je me permets de le
faire à nouveau
et de faire en sorte que
si je prends les étudiants que le champ
des possibles sur le même pour tous
ce qui veut dire en creux que être né en
Martinique ne doit pas devenir entre
guillemets une assignation à résidence
c'est-à-dire qu'on doit pas dire un
jeune Martiniquais ou un jeune
guadeloupéen parce que tu es né dans cet
territoire tu dois absolument y revenir
tout comme on ne peut pas dire un Breton
parce que tu es né en Bretagne il faut
que tu reviennes en Bretagne parce que
le territoire se dépeuple il me semble
que la promesse républicaine ne peut pas
être celle-là alors peut-être que je me
trompe peut-être que les les
orientations politiques me diront non
c'est ça qu'il faut faire il faut il
faut absolument qu'ils reviennent parce
qu'ils sont dans les territoires des
peuplé à mon sens ça promettrait
républicaine elle est pas celle-là par
contre c'est pour ça que je parlais de
mobilité dans les deux sens notre rôle
doit être aussi d'accompagner celle de
ceux qui veulent revenir ou qui veulent
venir
parce que je pense que ça peut concerner
et ça doit concerner les ultramarins qui
doivent revenir ça doit aussi concerner
n'importe quel français qu'un projet de
vie dans ces dans ces dans ces
territoires et ça je pense que c'est une
mission aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
inscrite dans le code des transports on
a pas le droit aujourd'hui de le faire
il faut être bien clair là-dessus et
c'est ce que je souhaite porter et je
peux vous dire que sans rien dévoiler
que le ministre est complètement ouvert
à cela et qu'il soit que la mobilité se
fasse dans les deux sens
à chaque fois que je l'ai vu c'est un
sujet qu'il a qu'il a qu'il a évoqué sur
la manière d'accompagner dans l'autre
sens ceux qui veulent revenir ou venir
dans les territoires ultramarins pour
quelques raisons que ce soit mais
notamment pour servir les besoins du
territoire et je fais le lien avec les
métiers en tension
nous partenariats ce qu'on développe
notamment avec les régions d'outre-mer
mais pas seulement il y a aussi des
partenariats et c'est ce qu'on fait des
quasiment toutes les régions avec les
régions en France hexagonale
nous permettent offrir
aux populations ultramarines des
formations dans les métiers en tension
et c'est ce qu'on va essayer de de
fléchir de promouvoir
aujourd'hui on le faisait dire on peut
tout azimut c'est-à-dire que c'est en
fonction du besoin personnel c'est que
c'était un projet individuel la personne
veut se former dans ce domaine on lui
donne la possibilité de le faire si ça
n'existe pas sur le territoire ou sur la
zone
en parallèle de ça ou avec ça il faut
qu'on puisse aussi avoir des dispositifs
existants sur les métiers en tension sur
chacun des territoires et là ce sont les
élus locaux sont les régions ce sont les
acteurs locaux qui doivent vous dire
quels sont les métiers en tension pour
qu'on puisse offrir cette offre enfin
proposer cette offre à celles et ceux
qui veulent se former et dire à celles
et ceux et c'est l'avantage d'avoir
autant d'antenne dans les dans la zone
en France hexagonale à celles et ceux
qui veulent s'implanter qui se projette
en outre-mer voilà quels sont
aujourd'hui les métiers en tension sur
lesquels tu peux éventuellement te
former si tu n'as pas la formation
pour aller travailler ou avoir des
chances d'obtenir un travail de manière
plus plus sécure donc c'est je pense que
je rejoins complètement madame la
sénatrice sur le fait que ce retour doit
être accompagner mieux accompagner et
c'est en tout cas moi c'est c'est
[Musique]
depuis que je suis en responsabilité ça
fait quelques semaines mais madame SVT
pourrait en témoigner c'est ce que je
dis à tous les acteurs que je rencontre
tous et je le dis on est complètement
aligné sur cet aspect là avec avec le
ministre donc j'ai bon espoir qu'on y
arrive et même Lisa le disait
ça dépendra aussi des moyens que nous
donnerons
les assemblées la représentations
nationales pour exercer ses missions ces
nouvelles missions parce que ce sont de
nouvelles missions aujourd'hui que que
l'on a pas donc on proposera tout cela
évidemment on fera les économies qu'il
faut où il faut mais qui dit nouvelle
mission d'une nouvelle organisation la
chance qu'on a ce qu'on a déjà des
antennes mais ça donnera forcément aussi
une nouvelle j'allais dire
réorganisation qui à mon sens rentrera
peut-être je m'avance peut-être un peu
mais on verra ce que ça ça va comme
indication financière mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est évidemment vous
serez associé à ses choix assez choix
stratégiques sur la question des talents
sur la partie chiffrée je laisserai
madame SVT le dire mais ce sont des
choses que l'on fait déjà et que l'on
veut développer quand je dis non là
aussi
entretien avec le ministre a été très
clair sur le fait que les talents et
notamment sur ce qu'il appelait les
talents c'est pour ça et derrière les
talents donc sont les acteurs culturels
les acteurs sportifs
puissent être accompagnés
si tenté qu'il sache aussi que que la
Dom propose cela aujourd'hui ce dont je
ne suis pas certain je n'ai pas encore
fait le tour des Outre-mer mais j'en
connais certains pour d'autres raisons
je suis pas certain que tous les
habitants les outre-mer sache que la
daube peut accompagner dans le mal
culturel des acteurs des des artistes ou
des ou des sportifs
donc ça il faut qu'on le développe il y
a un travail de communication à faire et
ça rejoint d'ailleurs la question de
l'accueil de la communication de la Dom
sur les territoires ce sera aussi un
travail
quand je parlais tout à l'heure de
consolidation de nos acquis c'est
exactement ça c'est-à-dire la Dom sur
les territoires pour devenir cet acteur
de la mobilité il doit être vu il doit
être connu et ça passe par évidemment de
la communication ça passe aussi par un
accueil de qualité un accueil
téléphonique de qualité
dont je serai là aussi madame SVT nous
dire ce qui a déjà été fait notamment en
matière d'outils informatiques j'étais
hier d'ailleurs en démonstration pour
améliorer cette cette accueil et il y a
et je rejoins complètement cette
réflexion
des personnes qui peuvent complètement
le faire de manière dématérialisée et en
faire on va faire en sorte que ce soit
optimal et des personnes et plus
nombreuses dans notre public que
peut-être dans d'autres publics qui
s'adressent à des administrations qui
n'ont pas cette capacité là de le faire
par voie de matérialiser et c'est pour
ça qu'on a des enceintes sur les
territoires sinon sinon on aurait même
pas de vocation à être présent
physiquement sur les sur les
départements où les régions d'autres
héros d'hexagone c'est justement parce
qu'il y a ce Buzzle accompagnement il
doit être amélioré et j'aurais
l'occasion d'en discuter avec les unes
pour ça comment est-ce qu'on peut en
fonction des des
environnements locaux faire en sorte que
l'accueil soit le meilleur possible mais
comprenez bien que l'accueil qu'on peut
qu'on peut qu'on peut faire à Mayotte je
vais lancer la tortani devant moi ou ou
ou en Guyane quand on voit les quartiers
entre saint-laurent-de-maroni et Cayenne
il peut pas être le même et donc il faut
qu'on adapte nos dispositifs et
d'accueil à au public et à
l'environnement local mais ça je
pourrais réellement vous apporter une
réponse définitive dans ce qui
d'ailleurs sera d'un projet 2024 sur ces
points là lorsque j'aurai fait le tour
de territoire ce sera fait avant la
avant la mi-2023 pour quelque chose soit
complètement opérationnel le plus vite
possible c'est vraiment une de mes une
de mes priorités donc Madame vedette
peut-être sur les éléments talents on va
dire
oui donc le dispositif talent
appelons-le comme ça et en place depuis
2021 et on rencontre assez peu de succès
mais ça rejoindra un des points qu'on
avait abordé avec Concorde quand on
s'était rencontrés au mois de juillet
c'est la communication donc nous avons
eu enfin les recours ont été assez
limités pour les sportifs il y a jusqu'à
trois déplacements par an pour les
jeunes espoirs qui sont qui sont
financés en partie pas dans leur
totalité pour les artistes c'est un
déplacement par an et pour les
doctorants et pose doctorants c'est
aussi un déplacement par an on a eu 21
demandes on a eu 21 bons délivré à ce
titre à ce titre là donc sur une année
entière on est très loin du compte
ça rejoint la question de la
communication
pour
pour légitimer nos propos on a fait une
étude de satisfaction
on a interrogé 57
000 bénéficiaires de la Dom depuis 2019
on a eu un excellent taux de retour donc
on au chiffre peuvent enfin sont
significatif pour les conclusions nous
avons un taux de recommandation
commençons par les choses positives de
94% un taux de satisfaction du public
encadré de 86% sur les moyens de
communication là effectivement ça
corrobore tout à fait ce que vous avez
dit mais je pense que ce que vous
remarquez aussi d'un mot territoire
c'est le on n'arrive pas à joindre la
Dom au téléphone on n'a pas toutes les
infos
et donc là on a déjà un court terme on a
déjà changé les horaires d'accueil
parce que les unités territoriales
étaient pas suffisamment ouvertes donc
on sait que quand quelqu'un a une envie
il faut répondre immédiatement sinon
demain elle peut être passée ou dans
trois jours elle peut être passée donc
il faut on a
augmenté nos horaires d'ouverture avec
minimum 5 heures d'ouverture par jour
lycée sur la semaine ou pas mais en tout
cas des horaires plus fixes on a
amélioré les la solution téléphonique
qui n'avait pas été revue depuis 2010 on
est passé sur la voie sur IP donc
maintenant il est message arrive
directement quand on y répond pas arrive
sur la boîte mail et on a des éléments
de de réponse plus facile on a testé sur
la Guyane il y a trois appels qui ont
pas été répondu sur 500 au mois de
janvier donc on s'améliore donc on a
aussi des on contrôle beaucoup plus et
on a des outils de contrôle aussi au
siège pour améliorer concrètement le
suivi et comprendre les difficultés on a
des spécificités aussi dans les dossiers
c'est vrai que sur
[Musique]
dans les territoires
donc on améliore donc on a aussi pris la
décision d'avoir une stratégie réseaux
sociaux donc maintenant nous sommes sur
les réseaux sociaux depuis le mois de
décembre avec des contenus
récurrents pour que on s'habitue on
connaît sur Instagram Facebook qui est
LinkedIn et Twitter et sur Youtube
sur YouTube sur la chaîne Youtube on va
aussi améliorer notre site internet
c'est à dire qu'on va dans très peu de
temps mettre en place un simulateur
d'aide pour que ce soit plus parlant aux
gens qui arrivent sur un site où ils
comprennent même pas où il faut aller
parce que c'est pas il est pas très
clair donc on va faire on améliore pour
être plus pratique au pratique plus
facilement accessible en tenant compte
on discute beaucoup avec madame attivel
qui est vice-présidente de la Région
Réunion sur les difficultés liées à
l'écriture et la lecture de la langue
française et du d'ailleurs on fait des
des spots en schémaoré pour qu'il soit
compris partout et le maximum on a fait
une campagne spécifique à Mayotte
l'année dernière qui a fait remonter les
chiffres de la de la de l'accessibilité
à nos services notamment en termes
d'acété donc on est on essaie d'être au
plus proche des diversités des
territoires pour pour communiquer sur la
meilleure raison et avec les meilleurs
outils
pour les dispositif particulier on a
aussi des dispositifs qui sont assez peu
connus encore comme l'accompagnement sur
les euros de concours
qui ne sont pas non plus assez connus
mais on va améliorer ça cette année
merci merci monsieur le Président de me
donner la parole si vous intervenons ma
collègue rapporteur que je salue a déjà
abordé beaucoup de questions moi j'avais
essayé mais vous l'avez déjà largement
aussi abordé c'est l'accès au droit et
quels sont les les personnes éligibles
dispositifs qui en aurait pas
connaissance et voilà c'est le sujet
majeur mais vous en avez parlé
travailler
à la mobilité et une façon large et pour
des mobilités professionnelles vous avez
l'intention développer le champ d'action
de de la Dom à une question sur est-ce
que vous avez évalué vous êtes en
réflexion sur une étude d'impact et sur
une budgétisation de ces élargissements
de de compétences pour vous avez dit que
ça dépend de la loi de finances mais il
faut pour ça pour qu'on la vote il faut
qu'on soit éclairé avec des données
chiffrées et des études d'impact qui
sont malheureusement
insuffisamment
fourni donc vous pouvez nous argument
développé là-dessus ce serait
intéressant
et je voulais venir sur revenir sur le
questionnaire peut-être un point que
vous n'avez pas abordé et qui est
souvent revenu dans nos auditions c'est
à la mobilité entre la métropole et les
outre-mer mais aussi cette mobilité
entre territoire
ultramarin
même quand il s'agit d'archipel déjà
interne et puis également entre
différents territoires ultramarins
est-ce que vous envisagez de renforcer
la participation financement pour
permettre cette mobilité renforcer ces
liens bien sûr entre la métropole et les
outre-mer et puis également les
outre-mer entre eux
et puis la question numéro 4 que vous
n'avez pas abordé là par rapport à en
2018 une décision du Défenseur des
droits alerté sur des difficultés
récurrentes rencontrées par des usagers
en particulier sur les délais de
traitement de vos demandes alors est-ce
que depuis cet alerte du Défenseur des
droits et ce qu'il y a eu des
améliorations d'apporter
et aussi votre regard sur le dispositif
Corse est-ce qui vous paraît
transposable à l'ensemble des Outre-mer
merci
alors sur le l'étude d'impact et
au jour d'aujourd'hui j'ai pas les
chiffres j'ai pas les chiffres parce que
les orientations n'ont pas été n'ont pas
été validés donc là vous connaissez
j'allais dire le rétroplanning les
oplf aujourd'hui on est au stade des
réflexions notre responsabilité j'allais
dire à tous les trois c'est de faire en
sorte de proposer proposer
au ministère de tutelle un projet
stratégique
qui doit d'abord justement dans ces
orientations être validées
des discussions etc le surnomme en
préparation donc il valideront en donner
des des
objets stratégiques nous appartient
ensuite en lien là aussi avec une star
de tutelle de budgétiser tout ça pour
inscrire cela dans dans le cadre du
processus qui amène ensuite au vote au
vote du PLF donc tout ça pour vous dire
que avant l'été tout cela tout cela aura
été budgétisé mais j'entends bien ce que
sur l'étude d'impact parce que
là dessus je pense qu'on sera les mieux
outillés pour alimenter
justement les effets et je veux dire le
le corps ou le principal corpus de ce de
cette étude d'impact qui sera évidemment
à la main des ministères de tutelle mais
il me semble que sur un outil aussi
particulier qui n'a pas beaucoup
d'équivalent
on se chargera tous les trois dans les
compétences qui sont les nôtres de faire
en sorte que c'est une impact soit la
plus étayée possible et que vous ayez du
coup maximum d'éléments pour pouvoir
prendre des décisions une décision
réfléchir en matière de de financement
de la DOM et de manière générale de la
mobilité des ultramarins que je souhaite
je le répète dans les deux sens
parler de la légère de la mobilité infra
régionale et du de la possibilité
de savoir si on renforçait le
financement de la mobilité intra
régional on n'a pas de ligne
particulière pour la mobilité infrar
régionale c'est la même ligne que l'on a
pour la mobilité qu'elle soit infrar
régionale ou en direction de l'Hexagone
ce que je souhaite parce que je
j'entends et c'est normal là aussi si on
pratique de communication c'est que l'on
soit plus clair sur ce qu'on appelle
mobilité et à quel moment on intervient
comme on disait lorsque la formation
pour prendre la formation
professionnelle n'existe pas sur place
ou est saturé
l'aide de la Dom est mobilisable
moi je vous souhaite instaurer un
deuxième niveau qui est celui de
l'annonce saturation ou l'inexistence de
cette de cette formation à l'échelle
régionale et donc pour faciliter
justement ces échanges aujourd'hui ils
ont déjà possible mon finance déjà de la
formation infrargée il y a aucun
problème aujourd'hui pour la pour la
financer absolument aucun ce qui peut
être limitatif c'est un aspect
communication et y compris là du coup
c'est regarde de notre côté devant notre
porte la connaissance aussi pour la CIP
de tous les dispositifs existants sur la
zone pour être force de proposition et
ça rejoint ce qui avait été dit sur
Madame SVT sur le nombre de dispositifs
quasi sur ces territoires et mon souhait
je le répète d'avoir la donne comme
j'aime pas trop le terme de guichet
unique mais en tout cas comme porte
d'entrée principale
de la mobilité en capacité de justement
apporter ce rôle de conseil
sur tous les dispositifs existants cela
donne mais aussi des autres et toutes
les formations possibles et imaginables
dans la zone la zone Caraïbe par exemple
ou
la zone de l'océan Indien pour pour ce
qui est de la Réunion et Mayotte cette
connaissance il faut qu'on la développe
moi je participerai début mars à la
conférence régionale
en Guadeloupe justement c'est ce sur ces
sujets là pour que on soit complètement
au fait et qu'on soit associé à ces
travaux sur sur la région d'autant plus
qu'on en tête comme tout le monde en
tête le fait que
on doit autant que faire ce peu avoir
en filigrane l'impact environnemental
aussi de ces déplacements de faire en
sorte d'optimiser les déplacements
pour le bien-être évidemment des des
individus qui à mon sens arriveront
mieux à suivre leur formation à réussir
lorsque l'environnement dans lequel il
se projette et
[Musique]
à des caractéristiques en tout cas et
moins différents ou le moins différent
possible de ce qu'il connaît déjà
lorsque on prend un tahitien et que l'on
voit à Strasbourg il peut y avoir des
difficultés sur la première année
totalement compréhensible tout comme
d'ailleurs quand on envoie un
Marseillais à Paris mais
je dis ça parce que je suis marseillais
si vous n'aviez pas entendu ou compris
mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'évidemment
j'allais dire la coopération régionale
passe aussi par ses par ses échanges
régionaux
auxquels les jeunes sont de plus en plus
ouverts ces deux hommes de plus en plus
une demande d'avoir justement cette
ouverture sur l'hormone régional
de pouvoir aller dans les pays de la
zone pas juste des zones françaises mais
aussi dans des pays de la zone on peut
imaginer par exemple pour Losser indien
que des formations en hôtellerie se
passent à l'île Maurice qui est réputée
dans ce domaine donc tout ça doit être
développé et et c'est ce que je souhaite
que la Dom face demain alors on obligera
jamais personne à dire bon s'il veut
absolument aller à l'Hexagone il est en
hexagone s'il y a la formation existe
pas sur son territoire mais en tout cas
ça lui sera proposé
ça lui sera proposé ensuite c'est un
choix de vie c'est une démarche
individuelle et je le répète moi je ne
souhaite pas
qui est d'assignation à résidence par
contre je souhaite que la Dom soit un
service
à un service pour le territoire
ultramarin ce qu'il n'était pas jusqu'à
présent
sur les stages dans le bassin de vie on
a des stages pour professionnels pour
les étudiants s'ils répondent à cette
à cette obligation enfin encore une fois
cette limite ou cette ouverture enfin
bref cette limite de
ils peuvent aller dans tous les dans
tous les pays qui ont une côte avec une
côte atlantique ou une côte Océan Indien
avec leur territoire d'origine donc ça
veut dire qu'en Caraïbes on peut aller
aux États-Unis au Canada et dans les
provinces du Canada pour faire un stage
professionnel pour l'instant c'est pas
les études mais c'est un stage
professionnel et puis pour l'océan
Indien effectivement il y a toutes les
côtes avec les pays africains avec
Maurice voilà on a avec l'Inde on peut
déjà faire ça et en 2022 on a à titre
expérimental on va en faire le bilan
permis aussi pour les étudiants ou les
étudiants mais les formations
professionnelles qui se passent en
hexagone de retour faire son stage sur
son territoire d'origine quand il y en a
un pour justement tisser le
professionnel directement sur le
territoire d'origine et pour faciliter
le retour on a on a fait ça en passant
par le conseil d'administration puisque
ce n'était pas prévu par la loi donc on
fait quelques expérimentations à ce
titre pour essayer de faire avancer les
choses
donc
dans notre contrat d'objectif et de
performance s'il y a un indicateur qui
dit qu'on doit payer en 15 jours donc là
on s'en approche donc on doit être à
20-22 20 22 jours
mais Défenseur des droits en 2018
c'était appuyé sur une situation très
compliquée de de dette importante en
2015 en fait qui maintenant résorbé on a
beaucoup plus de facilité à payer les
stagiaires
tantex si tentait qu'on est un dossier
complet mais on est dans tout cas le
chaînage en interne à la DOM et beaucoup
plus resserré beaucoup plus remarqué
compter suivi donc on s'est amélioré sur
ce point on doit être à 20 22 jours
une petite précision et propose
me le rappeler juste préciser notamment
pour les personnes servent à nous toutes
les interventions que l'on a ne peuvent
être faites que parce qu'elles sont
autorisées par le code des transports
on ne peut pas tout ça pour dire quoi
dire que parfois et c'est normal et on a
tous les jours on ne peut pas aller sur
des cas qui sont légitimes sur lesquels
on voudrait aller
qui sont qui tangente nos compétences
mais mais par les textes on ne peut pas
le faire c'est soit le code des
transports soit une autorisation qui
nous est donnée par le conseil
d'administration sur des
expérimentations en dehors de cela on
peut pas on peut pas bouger ça explique
parfois pourquoi on a du mal à répondre
à des sollicitations
sur des cas qui sont complètement
légitimes mais aujourd'hui on est on est
tenu et c'est normal par le code des
transports
quelque chose sur le sur les dettes
paiement
ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est de
minimiser le nombre de d'interlocuteurs
pour encore une fois c'est toujours la
même chose pour le bénéficiaire on a des
opérations où il y a la préfecture le
département
un prestataire plus la DOM et en fait le
bénéficiaire et c'est jamais à qui
s'adresser et on lui demande à papier
mais il sait jamais à qui le donner donc
ça ça allonge beaucoup les délais de
traitement donc c'est vrai que
on n'aime pas vraiment le terme de
guichet unique mais en fait il faudrait
qu'il y ait le moins possible
d'interlocuteur pour le suivi du
bénéficiaire pour qu'il sache comment
s'y retrouver dans tous les dispositifs
oui ça pourrait peut-être correspondre
sur les territoires à dégroupant de
moyens voilà j'imagine qu'il y a des
formules qui existent dans d'autres
secteurs qui pourraient inspirer
d'ailleurs tous les territoires je me
mettant laissé la parole à la salle donc
Marie et Laure finirahors et ensuite
Annie
oui merci président bonjour à tous Tout
d'abord je tiens à saluer le travail
effectué par la Dom pour accompagner les
mobiles les mobilités des résidents des
Outre-mer mais malheureusement je tiens
à soulever une injustice qui perdure
depuis trop longtemps les aides à la
continuité territoriale sont censés
couvrir 40% du prix du billet d'avion
c'est un taux et non pas un menton j'ai
effectué donc quelques recherches pour
préparer le rendez-vous d'aujourd'hui et
dans tous les cas de figure les familles
guyanaises auront toujours un reste à
charge supérieur à celui de famille
antillaise la faute bien entendu au
tarif pratiqué par les compagnies
aériennes qui desservent la Guyane
je rappelle que la moitié de la
population guyanaise vit sous le seuil
de la pauvreté et un tiers vit en
situation de grande précarité alors que
la Guyane a besoin d'avoir des forces
vives formées pour assurer son
développement trop de jeunes renoncent à
poursuivre leurs études en raison des
coûts exorbitants
tous les sénateurs ici ont tenté
d'infléchir l'inflation sur le prix des
billets d'avion mais son succès je me
tourne donc vers vous monsieur le
Président de la Dom que pouvez-vous
faire pour diminuer le reste à charge
des familles guyanaises et j'ai une
deuxième question les étudiants sont de
plus en plus nombreux à étudier plus
longtemps certains vont même jusqu'à 30
ans les causes sont nombreuses par
exemple manque d'informations lors de
l'orientation année de césure avait pour
raison familiale ou sociales est-ce que
vous pensez pas que la Dom devrait
relever l'âge maximum pour déposer un
dossier puisque là je maximum il me
semble que ces 26 ans voilà les deux
questions que je voulais vous poser
merci beaucoup merci je vais commencer
et puis je vous laisserai compléter
alors juste une précision sur l'acété
c'est bien un montant fixe
et pas un taux et effectivement c'est un
débat qu'il faut ouvrir on a commencé à
ouvrir en interglise récemment mais
c'est bien un taux fixe qui
effectivement identique sur la région
antiguahan et donc effectivement qui
prend en compte le prix du billet
d'avion
sur ça il y a deux points d'amélioration
ce qui nous travaillons le premier c'est
qu'il était voté une augmentation du
plafond donc il restera un tofix et qui
aura vocation du coup à moyenne ne plus
couvrir que 40% mais 50% en moyenne
puisque effectivement comme c'est au
fixe ça dépend des périodes le deuxième
levier clairement qu'il faut activer ce
qui nous travaillons c'est de faire en
sorte que les compagnies sur notamment
les billets aidés par la Dom puissent
je vais dire le mot plafonner sûrement
peut-être le prix du billet pour qu'au
moins le reste à charge soit sur mon
temps limité alors pour cela il y a deux
solutions la première c'est qu'elle joue
le jeu donc ce qu'elles ont ce que nous
faisons nous avons rencontré tous les
compagnies plusieurs reprises et il y a
clairement une volonté de trouver des
solutions notamment pour un public très
précaire qui est le public éligible
l'autre peut-être levier qui est
peut-être plus commercial c'est
peut-être que la Dom aussi change la
façon de procéder actuellement la Dom
émet un bon qui permet à chaque individu
de voyager avec la compagnie qu'il
souhaite donc les compagnies pour le
coup n'ont pas une raison particulière
peut-être qu'il faudrait
je parle mon nom choisir un opérateur ou
une compagnie parmi d'autres faire
parler vulgairement faire un deal et
peut-être qu'on échange de volume
garanti sur une durée combien de jours
voilà donc effectivement il y a les deux
leviers il faut que d'un côté côté état
que l'aide augmente ce qui était fait
c'est 6 millions d'euros de plus qui ont
été votés pour augmenter le plafond et
c'est qu'on est tout à l'heure c'est que
c'est ce qui est qui est très
enfin qui pour le coup est assez
compensé c'est que malgré ses aides
effectivement le public ne voit pas
l'aide moi les personnes me disent c'est
gentil de m'aider au final je voyage pas
donc tu pourrais m'aider à 1000 euros
10000 euros s'il me reste à payer un
montant supérieur à ce que je peux je
suis pas aidé dans le voyage pas donc
mon gars les deux leviers là le premier
levier était activé donc on a augmenté
le plafond de la CT qui reste au fixe
pour des raisons qui sont très
compliquées passer sur un taux variable
voilà ce qu'il faut trouver comment etc
mais donc c'est au fixe après
effectivement on travaille assez
activement sur comment une compagnie
mettre en place un dispositif qui va
mettre à minimum un minima sur les
billets par la Dom de plafonner pour que
le reste à charge reste bien 50%. et que
50% sur le plus bas possible
sur le deuxième sujet
je fais une aparté par contre sur la
Guyane effectivement il y a un sujet que
soulevait Monsieur le Directeur c'est
sur le le périmètre d'aide effectivement
certaines personnes qui doivent venir du
fleuve pour pouvoir prendre l'avion à
Cayenne les coûts transports entre leur
domicile et l'aéroport peuvent être
conséquent voilà moi j'habite aux avais
bien en Guadeloupe aéroport c'est facile
quand on vient déjà de la Basse-Terre
pour aller à l'aéroport en transport
c'est compliqué et qu'on vient de la
Guyane ou même de maillots tempéré
effectivement donc il y a un sujet quand
même sur le périmètre est-ce que le
l'aide commence à l'aéroport ou est-ce
qu'il faut pas dans certains cas façon
territoriale qu'elle commence au
domicile quand on sait que le coût de
transport entre le domicile et
l'aéroport est quand même important
donc il fait partie des sujets nouveaux
sur lesquels nous travaillons pour le
laidum 2024 sur l'âge effectivement je
pense que vous avez raison et donc aussi
nous partageons cela effectivement le
les habitudes font que les gens
rentrent en formation plus tardivement
et effectivement il y a maintenant des
cursus de plus en plus long donc et
notamment dans la volonté de permettre
aux gens de commencer le cursus dans le
territoire premier cycle deuxième cycle
de finir en hexagone ou ailleurs
effectivement il y aura un vrai sujet de
pouvoir élargir l'âge peut-être pas sur
le tout-venant mais au moins dans un cas
nos projets professionnels où il y a une
formation complémentaire en troisième
cycle ou même dans les phrases
complémentaires effectivement de
d'élargir large une piste de travers ce
qui nous travaillons pareil le roi
d'administratif n'est pas évident mais
sur laquelle enfin nous l'avons dans la
liste des choses améliorer et nous y
travaillons
si vous voulez compléter
alors sur
la question la question du prix d'avion
évidemment il y a un sujet
extrêmement important et
que j'ai commencé à regarder dès que je
suis arrivé
madame vitesse vous dira qu'elle soit du
poétique qui ont été mis en place
justement pour atténuer cette hausse du
billet avec
une politique de la Dom qui permet
justement d'essayer de tenir un peu les
prix
ce que je voulais vous dire quand même
de parler des échanges que j'ai pu avoir
avec les services concernés qui sont un
peu au fait de ces questions
c'est que
le prix kilomètres
pour les territoires d'outre-mer dans
cette période inflationniste
n'a pas pu augmenter que le prix
kilomètre sur des destinations type New
York etc et même et plutôt en dessous
l'augmentation a été a été moindre
par contre
ce qui est vrai et c'est ce qui donne le
ressenti en fait d'augmentation qui est
pas juste un ressenti qui est une
augmentation mais qui c'est que
l'écart-type entre la période hausse et
pas d'autres saisons et la période de
basse saison est plus importante sur
l'état de territoire d'outre-mer que kyr
et donc comme les personnes partent
surtout en période de haute forcément il
prenne de plein fouet l'augmentation qui
du coup est plus importante que sur les
autres destinations c'est ça en fait qui
est en train de se passer c'est à dire
que les écarts de prix on parle de
moyenne souvent mais la moyenne en fait
si vous avez
les pieds dans le four et la tête dans
le frigo en moyenne vous êtes bien né en
moyenne et donc il faut qu'on arrive à
avoir un écart type qui soit plus
raisonnable pour faire en sorte que
d'atténuer c'est pour ça que le
président parlait de de prix plafonné je
sais pas si
ce qui arrivera mais en tout cas dans
notre esprit c'est justement de
maintenir les coups y compris par
rapport à l'incidence que ça peut avoir
pour les finances publiques c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait le lien que tout
variable c'est-à-dire que
je vois à peu près je pense que vous
connaissez nos collègues du budget si on
part sur un taux variable avec
l'augmentation actuelle des des billets
qui dont on ne connaît pas la fin
en tout cas on a du mal à maîtriser à
savoir ce qui va se passer
je sais pas ce qu'on met comme ligne du
coup dans dans le plan de finances
et sur quelle base donc c'est à mon sens
plus compliqué ce qui est pas interdit
mais ce qui est plus compliqué par
contre en moyenne
on sera sur un taux de prise en charge
qui va augmenter parce qu'on a les
moyens plus importants
nous les outils qu'on a pour essayer de
faire en sorte que monsieur disja vous
disiez ce qu'on va essayer de faire avec
les compagnies avec tous les acteurs du
secteur pour justement aller vers encore
plus de facilité et un prix qui soit qui
soit moins élevé mais je tiens quand
même à dire en pour terminer que on est
aussi tenu et c'est normal sont les
règles par les règles européennes c'est
à dire que liberté de des tarifs je
pense que vous avez investigué ça aussi
bien que moi et beaucoup mieux on a
éventuellement la possibilité
l'OSP le service public de pouvoir avoir
des choses adaptées
j'ai pas répondu à votre question sur la
Corse c'est très honnêtement parce que
j'ai en fait j'ai pas la réponse j'ai
pas d'éléments en fait à vous donner sur
ce qui se passe réellement encore c'est
enfin j'ai pas investigué sur les
dispositifs particuliers ce que je sais
c'est qui sont très particuliers ça je
vous l'accorde
et alors là je parle en tant que
ultramarin ils sont pouvoir avoir la
même chose très je serai ravi
et
aujourd'hui on fait que ce qu'on a avec
les tests qui sont les nôtres ils m'ont
entendre directeur général j'applique
les textes et j'utilise des outils que
je peux que je peux avoir on se pose
même la question de savoir sur le marché
serait
j'allais dire une démarche intéressante
pour faire baisser les billets pour j'en
suis pas convaincu parce qu'il y a des
facteurs des territoires notamment comme
Mayotte ou on a quand même quasiment
monopole ou en tout cas très peu de
compagnies d'autres où il y en a
beaucoup plus donc tout ça est quand
même est quand même extrêmement complexe
et je pense que c'est aussi ce qui a
motivé vos travaux et on sera évidemment
très très intéressé de d'avoir vos
conclusions mais en tout cas au jour
d'aujourd'hui avec ce qu'on a comme
moyen qui ont été augmentés je le
rappelle par le ministre sur cette
question de de
on fait ce qu'on peut vraiment on peut
on fait ce qu'on peut et on prend en
sorte en 2024 d'avoir cette approche
territorialisée dans parler d'ailleurs
madame la scène il me semble être à mon
avis la meilleure approche pour
justement coller aux spécificités des
territoires et typiquement pour la
Guyane on est chose qui est spécifique
par rapport à la Martinique et la
Guadeloupe qui se rapproche beaucoup
plus
alors sur
le prix la contrainte du prix du billet
comme vous avez dû vous en rendre compte
la vraie échelle et la vraie difficulté
fin ce qui fixe les limites c'est
l'Europe en fait
et dans la zone Europe et donc il y a
des c'est très très contraint
c'est-à-dire que tout est enfin c'est
pas à l'échelle de la France la
concurrence est à l'échelle de l'Europe
et on a peu de la main sur ce qu'on peut
faire en France alors ado encore moins
mais c'est vraiment les décisions
européennes qui nous empêchent par
exemple de faire un marché qui pourrait
couvrir la totalité de nos besoins et
puis faire le lien avec les
bénéficiaires donc là où on peut avoir
effectivement peut-être une une marge
c'est sur
faut que les compagnies aériennes
comprennent qu'on suit leur coûts et
notamment sur la période de la haute
saison c'est le principal
principal travail qu'on peut effectuer
on travaille en interne avec la dgom et
des GAC sur le suivi des compagnies
aériennes et sur leur mise en place de
leur obligation et on a pu se rendre
compte que il y a une décision qui a été
prise en 2007 sur une obligation de
service public concernant les personnes
endoyer qui n'est pas mise en place en
fait et qui oblige les
compagnies aériennes à débarqué des gens
s'il le faut et à donner le prix le plus
bas sur le vol aux personnes qui
désiraient se déplacer c'est pas mis en
place il y a une espèce de surenchère en
2008 entre compagnie on va faire ci on
va donner des billets à 300 euros et en
fait maintenant ils ont il y a une
difficile application de ce texte donc
mais le SP l'OSP les obligations
services publics savent aussi au
développement économique des territoires
donc peut-être qu'on peut faire évoluer
puisque si la Dom n'est quand on forme
des demandeurs d'emploi quand on
travaille sur le projet du territoire je
pense qu'à un moment on peut ne rentrer
dans ce champ-là donc c'est une des
pistes qu'on va explorer pour essayer de
faire avancer ce sujet concernant la
Guyane il y a la continuité territoriale
intérieure dans le texte du code des
transports en Guyane Nouvelle-Calédonie
il y a la continuité territoriale
intérieure qui est dans le cas la Guyane
porté par le Département et la Dom
participe au prix pris en charge par le
département
donc c'est Annie finalement
nous on a calculé par rapport non pas au
prix des marchés au prix du billet des
marchés mais vraiment là avec le prix
auquel achète les personnes enfin les
billets le coup pris dans notre outil à
cet été en fait et dans notre outil en
fait les gens sont déjà très économes
donc ils prennent leur billet très en
amont quand ils le peuvent puisqu'on a
aussi un phénomène de personnes qui
veulent accompagner leur enfant qui
étudie la première année donc là ils
prennent leur bio dans les moments mais
ils anticipent les billets commencent à
être achetés au mois d'avril pour l'été
dans notre système on le voit très
nettement et donc on a calculé le prix
moyen du billet de notre outil donc
haute période basse période et à partir
de ces moyennes là on a établi trois
propositions 40-45 50% et le ministre a
choisi 50% pour être Rome et les com et
donc ce taux là va être suivi pour pour
voir si on est toujours à 50% en même
temps si on y a des territoires où ça a
beaucoup moins augmenté l'effet
augmentation c'est qu'en 2021 les prix
étaient très bas en 2020 bon on parle
pas du trafic aérien en 2020 mais en
2021 les prix étaient très bas donc là
on a l'impression que ça a beaucoup
augmenté mais en fait on est à peine
dans certains territoires on a à peine
au niveau 2019 je pense là à la
Guadeloupe donc c'est la perception et
la réalité on est on n'est pas toujours
en adéquation
merci Président je vous remercie pour
vos propos très éclairants je rejoins
mes collègues et ma question
s'orienterait justement sur ce coup de
de 40% avez-vous
mené une étude d'impact pour savoir quel
serait effectivement l'impact si le
législateur proposait que ce que cette
participation soit effectivement de 40%
au lieu d'un bon pour rejoindre aussi
savoir telemy qui est une petite île on
parlait tout à l'heure monsieur le
Président vous parlez de Basse-Terre
pour aller à Pointe-à-Pitre prendre
l'avion moi je veux parler de
Saint-Barthélémy pour aller à
Pointe-à-Pitre il faut savoir que le
prix du billet est autour c'est le maïs
le plus cher au monde autour de 600
euros pour une heure de vol je pense
aussi à mes collègues de la de la
Polynésie qui parfois de les îles
Marquises qui ont quatre heures de vol
pour rejoindre Tahiti donc est-ce que
l'on pourrait envisager justement que
billet dans le prix du billet le départ
de la destination initiale jusqu'à la
destination finale et pouvoir apporter
une aide en fonction de ses billets donc
ce serait c'était ma première question
et la deuxième très rapide c'est que bon
on parle beaucoup de rapatriement de
corps de deuil mais dans des cas
extrêmement rares parfois il y a des
étudiants qui perdent le parent de
manière tout à fait brutale qui qui est
le seul source d'aide est-ce que la Dom
prévoit prévoit un dispositif un peu
spécifique pour encadrer au mieux ces
étudiants qui se retrouvent brutalement
privés de sources de revenus je vous
remercie
sur l'étudiant je prends à l'envers mais
pour les étudiants qui ça arrive c'est
arrivé encore très récemment avec une
jeune femme de Nouvelle-Calédonie
effectivement la dame n'a pas de
dispositif qui permet de prendre en
compte cette demande peut le faire à la
marche mais c'est pas normé donc
on projette de faire
on étudie dans le cadre de la dame 2024
la mise en place d'un fond social la Dom
qui pourrait prendre peut-être en charge
cette situation là on peut rien faire
financièrement mais encore
l'accompagnement humain qui est offert
par la Dom dans les territoires
hexagonaux a permis de trouver une
solution quand même pour cette personne
là entre l'employeur et les
collectivités locales on a réussi à
faire arriver cette personne à temps
pour les obsèques de son père et pour
passer une période de deuil sur place
donc on a un suivi qui nous permet
d'avoir un réseau pour aider mais on n'a
pas de fonds propres c'est en ça qu'il
faut faire évoluer ce système sur la
participation effective à 50% au lieu du
bon
on n'a pas fait l'étude d'impact assez
compliqué parce que on a pléthore de
convention avec les compagnies aériennes
sur Terre par territoire des conventions
par territoire avec les compagnies
aériennes avec les agences de voyages et
c'est on n'a pas fait cette étude encore
mais comme un rêve à faire sans doute
mais en fait c'est c'est
ce serait le système le plus souple pour
le pour l'usage et en tout cas
vraiment parce que quand on ne maîtrise
pas le prix du billet et que le prix du
billet libre le 50% il peut être 1000
euros aujourd'hui et 2000 et donc c'est
pour ça que la piste c'est vraiment de
travailler des compagnies pour qu'au
moins sur les billets la Dom qu'on
puisse maîtriser le plafond que sinon
effectivement le directeur la ligne
budgétaire on peut pas la plafonner et
donc dans un budget on pourrait pas dire
ça coûtera à 10 millions 20 millions
parce que ça peut varier du jour au
lendemain c'est là où il y a des
difficultés
je disais que si
il y a une étude d'impact nous avons une
marge de manœuvre avec avec un maximum
et un minimum et notre rôle aussi c'est
de plaider dans le cadre du projet de
votre finance pour pouvoir avoir pour
abonder les fonds donc nous avons réussi
à hauteur de 9 millions me semble-t-il 8
millions plus deuxième amendement un
million c'est déjà un peu de beurre dans
les épinards donc l'objectif c'est
vraiment d'accompagner parce qu'il y a
de réelles souffrances et comme le
disait fort justement des étudiants qui
préfèrent renoncer qui a de vrai de
réels potentiels mais qui préfère
renoncer parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
famille n'a pas les moyens d'accompagner
ces étudiants par contre il y a
peut-être une piste parce qu'on en
brainstorm même du coup je me permets
peut-être une piste Explorer qui serait
peut-être de trouver comment
déjà le cas dans certains cas comment
les prix des billets valentertainment
soit indexé sur des prix des billets en
hexagone alors dans une prise de travail
qui date de la délégation mais c'était
bien avant moi d'ailleurs c'était
peut-être en 2014 je crois il
travaillait sur en disant voilà le prix
du vol le plus cher en hexagone de
mémoire c'était un vol je crois entre
Brest et Bordeaux alors pourquoi je sais
pas mais bon c'était le plus cher voilà
ça coûtait tant et donc un vol entre
l'hexagone et l'outre-mer de pas coûter
plus de temps en plus et donc du coup le
fait d'indexer au moins sans plafonner
mais indexé permettait d'arriver
effectivement à une sorte de plafond
qu'on peut pas GT mais tant qu'on a pas
un index ou un plafond on pourra jamais
quantifier le coût pour l'État et donc
la piste du taux variable restera
compliqué malheureusement
sur la partie trajet domicile aéroport
l'inconvénient de d'intervenir vers la
fin c'est que tout a été dit
moi je voudrais commencer par saluer la
nouvelle équipe de la Dom
nous fondons beaucoup d'espoir en vous
ce président sur le directeur général
madame la secrétaire général mais le
hasard fait que vous connaissez très
bien nos territoires tous les bassins
donc
les les
étudiants les jeunes en tout cas
[Musique]
ont envie que les difficultés
en 5 menuisant et fonde beaucoup
beaucoup d'espoir
les tous les sujets ont été abordés mais
je voulais juste dire avec quel acuité
celui posé par Marie-Laure se pose à
Mayotte la fierté des billets
dans le département le plus pauvre
ou 77% de la population vit en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté et où Saïd tu l'as
soulevé tout à l'heure il y a un quasi
monopole d'une compagnie d'aviation donc
on ne va pas faire
de concurrence pour savoir quel est le
billet le plus cher mais je crois que
deux Mayotte en bas en bas un record de
fierté du billet donc je rejoins ce que
ce que disait Marie-Laure
vous y aviez vous y avez déjà répondu
l'autre question que je voulais poser
vous l'avez un peu abordé aussi c'était
c'est quelle articulation il y a entre
les dispositifs de la DOM et les aides
et autres dispositifs des collectivités
notamment notamment du département le
jeûne ne sait pas il y a la limite se
moque de savoir qui fait quoi
l'essentiel c'est qu'il soit pris en
charge et je pense que
en matière de coordination en matière
d'articulation
il y a des des progrès à faire donc
est-ce que vous pouvez vous pouvez nous
en dire davantage et corollaire à cette
question c'est
aussi la coordination avec les
établissements scolaires ou avec les
organismes tels que le Service Militaire
Adapté
comment se passe la situation actuelle
et qu'envisagez-vous pour pour
l'améliorer au profit de nos jeunes
merci
monsieur le sénateur
[Musique]
sur la charte du pays c'est que Mayotte
a
c'est presque
l'exemple l'exemple
et pas dire le pire mais le plus
emblématique de cette probaique là où on
a à la fois un territoire
qui est parmi l'un des plus pauvres de
France et un prix du billet qui est
parmi le plus élevé non je passe et vous
avez raison Madame sénatrice sur sur
notamment les comme vous là vraiment
c'est on atteint les sommets mais mais
c'est vrai que à l'échelle à l'échelle
le meilleur les prix sont juste
extraordinairement exorbitant
on a tous en tête je pense que c'est la
tort aussi de famille qui veulent
voyager on est sur des pâtes tirs de 10
15000 euros c'est
énorme c'est énorme et donc c'est vrai
que c'est une problématique qui touche
parce qu'on parle de continuité
territoriale qui touche au fond de
moi-même de de la République on a un
vrai sujet on a un vrai sujet qui nous
rattrape avec cette inflation mais qui
se posait déjà qui se posait déjà avant
pour le saint indien pour les
territoires particuliers ce sont des
enjeux qui sont devant nous
collectivement d'ailleurs devant nous
pour savoir comment est-ce qu'on assure
cette continuité territoriale est-ce que
l'exemple Corse pourra nous aider à
aller plus vite plus loin ou pas je ne
sais pas en tout cas je pense que il est
plus que temps d'investiguer dans ce
domaine et au sein de la Dom pour ce qui
est de nos compétences et de ce qu'on de
ce qu'on pourra faire nous on poussera
évidemment tous les tous les leviers
possibles
autant que possible parce que là aussi
quand il y a pas de concurrence c'est
quand même assez compliqué c'est ça que
je parlais tout à l'heure du marché
qu'il allait être si on devait le lancer
serait quand même assez problématique
sur scène des territoires quand vous
avez un monopole vous lancez le marché
la compilation elle répond pas elle
répond pas de toute façon le marché
infectieux et elle continue à faire
appliquer ces prix et donc c'est ce
travail là comme un avec le président
avec le avec le ministre pour faire en
sorte que les compagnies avec les
compagnies un travail commun pour
travailler sur cette sur ce sur ce sujet
étant est entendu aussi que les
contraintes qui s'opposent aux
compagnies ils voulaient qu'on ait aussi
bien que moi notamment financière
certaines sont en très grande difficulté
et donc il faut aussi avoir ça en tête
lorsqu'on veut travailler directement
avec les compagnies il se posent la
question de des agences de voyages et
leur place dans le dispositif parce
qu'on est quand même un gros compte et
donc c'est tout un pan qui irait vers
les compagnies pas et qui passeraient
plus parler par les agences alors qu'on
a quand même de l'emploi local donc tout
ça est un vrai est un vrai sujet auquel
il faut qu'on s'attelle et croyait bien
qu'on est complètement
j'allais dire mobiliser sur sur la
question et et vous pourrez compter sur
nous en tout cas pour vous allez vous
amener les Allemands nécessaires mais
c'est une réponse en tout cas une
question vraiment qui dépasse qui moi me
heurte qui me touche parce qu'on touche
vraiment à des questions qui me sont là
depuis des questions même de cohésion
nationale sur la coordination qu'on a
maintenant avec les avec les autres
dispositifs existants alors vous avez
évoqué le SMA bon le SMA il se trouve
qu'on est au même endroit et ils sont
mis sur l'autre main on est aussi dans
la comparation elle est pleine entière
j'ai vu le général très récemment
il y a zéro sujet sur sur la question
c'est un très beau dispositif que vous
connaissez bien mieux que moi et dès
qu'il y a un projet de mobilité sur les
territoires le lien se fait
naturellement je sais plus où il me
semble que c'est en Guyane on est
quasiment accolé d'ailleurs en
Guadeloupe où on est à collé au logo du
SMMA donc il y a zéro sujet sur la
collaboration avec le SM
alors le
moi je reviens sans rentrer dans le
détail des collaborations qu'on peut
avoir sur tel ou tel territoire mais sur
ce que vous avez très bien évoqué et
auquel la question à laquelle on va
essayer de répondre c'est d'avoir ce ce
cette personne qui va suivre le
bénéficiaire du début jusqu'à la fin
mais c'est une question lancinante qu'on
rencontre dans les services publics
d'emploi qu'on rencontre dans le domaine
de la santé comment faire en sorte que
lorsqu'il y a un besoin qui exprimé qui
est pas de perte
en Martinique par exemple déjà quelque
chose qui existe
dispositif qui a été mis en place de
collaboration entre les différents
organismes avec une fiche de liaison qui
fait que lorsque
un jeune homme moins jeune s'adresse à
des organismes l'affiche est envoyée à
celui qui le reçoit ensuite la personne
est appelée donc voilà il est pris par
la main entre guillemets si je puisse
exprimer ainsi pour que son projet qui
est pas justement de de de de perte de
projet en tout cas que limiter parce
qu'il y a toujours c'est pas possible en
tout cas limité
le
l'échec potentiel de ce projet de ce
projet de vie je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à l'instaurer sur tous les
territoires notamment pour nos publics
notamment pour nos pépic et donc
j'appelle de mes vœux cette
collaboration avec tous les partenaires
possibles et imaginables qui travaillent
sur cette question-là mobilité je
souhaite que la donne sur les
territoires soit la porte d'entrée de la
mobilité dès qu'on pense mobilité il
faut qu'on pense la dame et ce sera la
mission que je confierai la Dom si je
suis validé dans cette stratégie que le
que les CIP accompagnent les porteur un
projet du début jusqu'à la fin
qu'ils aient une aide de la DOM ou pas
et à mon sens je pense qu'on aura
beaucoup plus de personnes d'ailleurs
qui s'adressera à nous qui ne
bénéficieront pas de dispositif de la
donne que le pays que le personnes qui
qui en bénéficient et notamment si on
travaille sur l'hexagone avec le cette
question du retour
mais se posera aussi la question et là
c'est un travail collectif ça rejoint un
peu je sois un peu du cadre mais la
question de Madame la science est-ce
qu'on code sur
l'attractivité du territoire
on va être devant un premier constat dès
la première année si on ouvre cette
possibilité de savoir pourquoi certains
territoires sont demandés puisque
d'autres lorsqu'on aura ouvert cette
possibilité du retour pour la Martinique
pour la Guyane pour la Réunion etc on
aura des territoires qui vont faire le
plein et d'autres qui le font moins en
tout cas il y aura plus de monde et donc
là à mon sens ça nous poussera
collectivement avoir sur chacun de ces
territoires une stratégie pour améliorer
l'attractivité de de certaines îles
pourquoi est-ce que la réunion ne perd
pas de population pourquoi d'autres
territoires en perdent ça c'est une
question qu'il faut avoir à laquelle il
va falloir répondre collectivement et
parce que Maëlle le disait le disait
la Dom peut porter beaucoup de
responsabilités je pense qu'on a on a
notre part dans le dans ce qui se passe
dans ces territoires dans ce qui
fonctionne bien et peut-être aussi dans
ce fonctionnement moins bien mais sur la
question de la guerre de
l'appauvrissement humain de ces
territoires honnêtement je pense que
c'est pas du côté de la Dom qu'il faut
qu'il faut regarder
et donc moi j'appelle level là aussi je
travaille collaboratif sur chacun de ces
Tyler territoire pour travailler sur les
métiers de tension sur l'attractivité
sur les besoins des personnes qui
veulent s'implanter sur des écoles de
qualité etc etc c'est ça qui fait qu'à
un moment donné les gens s'implant tout
simplement pas sur la qualité du réseau
Internet
fibre papier
depuis la Guadeloupe à Martinique la
Guyane alors que le bureau est à Paris
on a tous des exemples là par un
confinement de personnes qui sont allés
très loin pour aller travailler pourquoi
pas dans nos îles il y en a eu moins
dans nos îles posons-nous la question
collectivement de savoir pourquoi est-ce
que c'est territoire n'ont pas fait
voilà le plein entre guillemets de
télétravailleurs notamment des plus
jeunes voilà ça c'est un travail qui
qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'on a ensemble
en tout cas pour les compter sur nous
sur
la nécessité en tout cas à mon sens dès
qu'une personne s'adresse à la DOM ou un
projet de mobilité il faut qu'on s'en
occupe parce que là on n'est pas sur une
prestation sociale qu'on ne verse pas et
qu'on pourra rattraper le mois d'après
un jeune ou moins jeune qui renonce un
projet de vie c'est une vie qui qui part
d'un côté enfin qui prend pas le chemin
qu'elle devrait prendre donc c'est là où
on c'est là où je sens moins le poids de
responsabilité de faire en sorte qu'on
ne perde aucun bénéficiaire potentiel
qui s'adresse à nous que la Dom soit
connue que ceux qui doivent s'adresser à
la domment le fasse et que nous on fasse
notre job de la compagnie du début
jusqu'à la fin c'est ça notre mission
elle est pas ailleurs merci peut-être
une dernière question avant de continuer
nos travaux de la matinée avec Vivette
Lopez oui je serai brève parce
qu'effectivement le temps court là ça
sera plus un petit peu des réflexions
donc je voulais dire à madame zedez vous
avez parlé qu'il fallait essayer de
faciliter les documents à remplir je
crois que c'est vraiment important parce
que j'avais cru comprendre que quelqu'un
qui était trompé dans ces documents il
passait son tour donc bon peut-être
faudrait-il vraiment améliorer ces
documents
surprenant aussi ce que vous avez dit je
crois que c'est Monsieur et Madame que
le c'était l'Europe qui fixe peut-être
monsieur vous ditesa qui est fixez les
prix il me semble que il y a peu de pays
européens qui ont des territoires
intra-marins mis à part la France
peut-être les Pays-Bas donc c'est quand
même nous la France qui sommes dessus
qui devrions un petit peu voir cela et
puis je reprenais aussi monsieur à
Madame ce que vous avez dit un jeune qui
vient faire des études pour trois ans en
France et qui peut être à Noël a envie
au bout d'une année de repartir ce qui
est tout à fait compréhensible en
sachant qu'au moment des fêtes de Noël
le prix des billets bah du simple double
donc l'aide est-ce qu'elle est de 40 50
% ou est-ce que c'est un préfixe bon si
vous voyagez au mois d'octobre aussi
voyagez au mois de décembre et puis tu
tournes près quand on est étudiant à ne
pas les moyens voilà c'était juste une
petite réflexion je demande pas
particulièrement de réponse mais voilà
merci en tout cas pour toutes les
explications que vous avez donné merci
beaucoup
rapidement sur le sur le billet de Noël
aujourd'hui là il y a pas de billet à
Noël donc il y a même pas la question
des 40% 50% du bon il y a pas de billets
il y a un seul billet un pour partir
l'autre pour rentrer à la fin des études
et ce que je souhaiterais c'est qu'il y
a un billet justement
qui puisse être pris à Noël aujourd'hui
on a même pas le principe de l'accord de
principe d'avoir ce billet là ensuite on
verra si on est sur du on peut le
financer aujourd'hui en tout cas si on
rate on reste sur des règles actuelles
c'est 100% ou 50% du billet 100% s'ils
sont boursiers et donc là il y a pas de
question de de plateforme etc et 50% et
là se pose au plafond pour ceux qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas boursiers pour
ce qui est des règles européennes je
pense que vous aurez le temps
d'investiguer mais oui on a on est
contraint par certaines règles qui font
que il y a une liberté de tarif qu'on
peut difficilement contraint une
compagnie à appliquer des prix sur faire
passer à marcher enfin il y a quelques
règles auxquelles il faut qu'on s'adapte
c'est normal mais c'est pas vous avez
raison c'est pas l'Europe qui est fixait
tarifs ce sont les compagnies
mais toutes les compagnies peuvent aller
dans les outre bien personne ne peuvent
les en empêcher elles peuvent appliquer
les tarifs qu'elle souhaite et mise à
part l'obligation de service public au
niveau européen on n'a pas d'autres
moyens de contraindre à une baisse des
prix particulière si ce n'est pas passé
par un marché ou éventuellement du
créateur c'est-à-dire s'entendre avec
des compagnies pour que les accepte
de leur propre fait de baisser le billet
les plafonner
la question pour l'Europe c'est en fait
c'est difficile à contourner et on peut
pas les contourner parce que ce sont des
règles mais du coup ça c'est pas le
tarif qui est fixé par l'Europe mais
c'est vraiment les règles de la
concurrence qui nous empêche de d'être
plus agile
merci beaucoup écoutez je vous remercie
vraiment de la qualité de ces échanges
et vous trouverez toujours au Sénat un
soutien actif et déterminé et détermine
à Catherine pardon excuse-moi Catherine
je pense que tu demandais la parole oui
président ça sera rapide merci beaucoup
je voulais dire à nous interlocuteur
d'avoir de ne pas se restreindre la
première audition que nous avons eu ça a
été celle de la course et aujourd'hui on
se rend compte avec la jurisprudence
cause entre guillemets que les histoires
de code du transport les histoires de
l'Europe et tout tout ça vaut leur nez
là et aujourd'hui un système
profondément
idyllique en Corse la cause et la France
la Martinique c'est la France la Guyane
c'est la France La Réunion c'est la
France Mayotte c'est la France aussi
donc inspirez-vous de la Corse
qu'on arrête aussi dès qu'il s'agit de
nous de parler de budget de PLF etc je
rappelle que la course a le même nombre
d'habitants que la Martinique et
pourtant au dernier PLF on a augmenté la
dotation de la cause de près de 40
millions d'euros ou fière face à
l'inflation etc la construction avec une
DSP je rappelle aussi que plus de la
moitié de l'année étant basse saison
dans les pour les billets d'avion avec
aujourd'hui des avions vous imaginez
bien que je voyage très souvent au moins
deux fois par mois et qu'il m'arrive
certes en ce moment puisque c'est
l'hiver d'avoir des avions pris à
craquer mais il m'arrive aussi de
voyager dans des avions de plus de 400
places dans lesquelles il y a 40
passagers donc ne serait-ce que sur les
plages dites verte dit basse saison des
avions on peut trouver les moyens de
mieux servir cette continuité
territoriale il y aussi des systèmes
dans d'autres pays européens qui ont des
territoires entre guillemets le Camaret
il y a pas que les Pays-Bas collègues il
y a aussi le Portugal et l'Espagne de ce
côté là du côté des canals du côté de
Madère il y a aussi des systèmes qui ont
été mis en place et qui sont pourtant
régies par le même code européen de
transport etc donc vraiment j'appelle la
Dom à faire preuve d'ambition de ne pas
se restreindre on verra après comment on
rabote à la manche mais quand je regarde
ce qui se passe encore je le dis haut et
fort que les autres territoires
ultramarins sont en situation
extrêmement défavorable injuste et
inéquitable par rapport au système
course donc soyons ambitieux visez haut
visez loin en tout cas nous on sera
derrière pour dire à l'état que la
France ne s'arrête pas à la course
en matière de continuité territoriale la
cause assure 50 ans à peu près de
pratique de continuité territoriale mais
ils se sont pas ils n'ont pas été
restreints ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
et
idyllique dans la République
idyllique dans la République sans
condition de ressources sans limitation
dans l'année avec des montants qui ont
qui sont sur des DSP avec les compagnies
aériennes si je prends le cas de la
Martinique et au moins trois compagnies
qui dit sur la Martinique depuis la
France et bien je pense qu'il y a moyen
de trouver des marchés des choses comme
ça mais je vous je vous le dis soyons
ambitieux parce que ça risque si notre
rapport accouche d'une souris et que
derrière il n'y a pas des moyens
ambitieux qui sont donnés à la
continuité territoriale je peux vous
dire que la rupture qui est déjà immense
dans certains territoires avec la
République va s'enfoncer encore plus
donc je vous le dis ne soyez pas rester
dans vos demandes ne vous embêtez pas
avec des histoires de budget laisser
nature les députés et parlementaires
sont là pour travailler les PLF et tout
et on saura dire à la France que la même
manière qu'on trouve des dizaines de
millions d'euros pour la cause pour la
continuité territoriale soit aujourd'hui
plus de 200 millions pour un équivalent
habitant
identique à celui de la Martinique et
bien qu'il faudra aussi de trouver des
moyens pour Mayotte pour Guyane pour la
Réunion etc là-dessus je peux vous dire
que je vais être ferme je vais être
extrêmement ferme et viative pour que
l'équité dans la République soit mieux
répartie et qu'il y ait un meilleur
traitement sans sans condition sang
voilà le code de ceci le code de cela
les causes ne se sont pas embarrassés de
ça c'est pourtant la France n'oubliez
pas non plus je conclus dessus que nous
avons un régime de whip qui est
dérogatoire avec le 349 3 au traité au
traité de traiter de de Lisbonne et qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui il y a des choses
qui sont possibles dans la République
exemple toi le meilleur qui n'est pas du
tout prévu par les textos
donc les dérogations sont possibles donc
de grâce ne soyons pas limités ne soyons
pas dans ces possibles c'est pas
possible on verra et cetera nous
veillerons à ce que les principes de
continuité territoriales soient aussi
ambitieux pour les territoires dit
ultramarins que ceux qui aujourd'hui mis
en cause au sein de la République je
vous remercie
merci de ce cri du coeur en guise de
conclusion chère Catherine je pense que
tu as tout dit et donc merci de votre
présence vous savez maintenant ce qu'il
vous reste à faire inspirez-vous de nos
amis corses en tout cas bonne fin de
journée merci à bientôt